hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel today
i'm going to be reacting to poo sheisty
the real
menace of south memphis i have no idea
what any of that means but apparently
this is some rapper beef
personally i watch the kardashians i
watch the bachelor
i know everything that's going on in
that world in this world like the rap
game
not so much before i start the video do
not forget to like comment and subscribe
especially subscribe
look the more subscribers i get on here
the more motivated i am to keep creating
content so every subscriber
i think to myself dang i should keep
creating content
and comment below let me know if i get
this rap stuff right
because i love a good like celebrity
gossip so i'm excited to like
catch up on this oh it's a real
i gotta keep it so 100. i ain't never
like you good
i ain't gonna lie ain't never like yo i
don't like it
[Music]
when i was hustling i was playing
memphis rappers i felt like they had
such
okay so it looks like in the beginning
he said he didn't like someone
on the um his live stream
which okay like
who cares right underground scene that's
what i that's what i gravitated to like
the most god of music is what i want to
hear
police and prosecutors say poo sheisty
was part of the group that ended up in
this parking lot that october afternoon
where the shots flew and it happened
right across the street from the police
department
and town hall here in bay harbor islands
hi what's up everybody
probably the most requested artist for
me i just got a comment if you're gonna
do
like a shootout why why would you do it
across from the police department
like i mean i don't know how much say
you got
like when you're like do you plan a
shootout or like if you just
it just happens but like if i was gonna
do a shootout
not that i would but like if i was i
would think to myself like
maybe don't do it across from the police
station but that's that's just my two
cents don't
let me tell you how to live the most
requested artist for me to make a video
on right now is poo scheisti it's one of
the biggest movements in rap and is
coming out of memphis
but for a lot of folks it feels like he
came out of nowhere last week
sheisty was second only to drake for the
most streamed artist in the country
there's a reason everyone's drawn you
know what's crazy
i'd never heard of this guy until i
started doing these videos like
i think i've done a video or two by him
before
so i like that's why i know the name but
like for real before
i started doing these videos i never
heard of him
push ice these crew chopper gangs gotta
be one of the wildest in the industry
and the music reflects it doesn't matter
how many billboards all over the country
have his face on it doesn't matter he's
signed to a major label deal with gucci
and atlantic selling 60k the first week
on his debut album
sheisty will still rob a dude in miami
who was trying to sell him weed and some
jordans
stick two shooters on the guy sending
him to the hospital escaping a green
mclaren
get arrested bond out and leave the
state in a private jet
why okay
this is this is what i don't understand
so like
i understand like why people would want
to steal stuff
like when you're poor because when
you're poor you can't afford it
but like why in your head would the best
option to be to rob the drug dealer
and then have to pay bail and then you
end up spending more money like what was
what was the point of that like i'm not
don't let me tell you how to live
saying the two left the state in a
private jet who they got the right guy
see she keeps his circle small you
basically gotta give your life to choppy
gang
just to be around chop a gang hank he's
locked up for an attempt murder
allegedly shot up a car and
paralyzed the dude in a bad case of
mistaken identity chop a walk he's down
for a murder and two attempts
even what
again i really
i i don't know much about like the crime
life i don't know much about it
but you would think if you were gonna
shoot somebody that you
you would make sure it's them like
attention to detail people kennedy chop
a whopped
he's down for a murder and two attempts
even sheisty's best bro big thirty who
was signed to a deal way before sheisty
was getting tens of millions of streams
a month
he got booked two weeks before sheisty
did on felony drug charges in alabama
got extradited back to memphis for
another penny case he was already
fighting
made bond and released the song first
day out but most of the mainstream was
not tuned in
until lil dirk and scheiste came
together to make the song back in blood
oh my gosh i've listened to both of
those songs for the reaction
oh oh this just
a couple things clicked here i'm back in
blood
and while most fans were focused on dirk
in the wake of the quando and von
situation
the entire city of memphis was focused
on shaisti's verse
because he wasn't just rapping tristy
was talking about a specific event that
happened
where he and two members of his crew
went to a rival house in memphis
and robbed a bunch of guns from them
that's why in the lyrics he says
yeah you know who took that [ __ ] from
you come get it back in blood
on the song chastise okay that's a bold
move
like
does anybody else just not really
understand like the point
like you're gonna steal something
and then tell them you stole it like
and
you know what i'm i'm not going to tell
you how to commit crime
i'm not going to tell you how to do that
and directly to them we ain't mad
we want
[Music]
the rival gang's called ebg and
demonstrates the event problems for
many years locally in memphis ebg being
from the north
sheisty being from the south it plays
into this divide that's long existed in
the city
but now the back and blood song is
worldwide hitting the number a spot on
billboard charts
getting 50 million views on youtube in
one month forcing ebg who
aren't even rappers to respond over the
same backing blood beat
their remix got taken down a bunch of
times each time getting hundreds of
thousands of views in days
so ebg dropped a second diss track this
one called rumors
they even got quando rondo to make an
appearance taking collateral shots at
dirk
i'd like to preface and say i have no
idea who any of these people are
like at all just for being on the
original song with sheisty
now we're gonna get into all this but
first check out my song of the day this
is some motivation from my guy k
johnny let's go to the point on good
[ __ ] mode just thought i should
[ __ ] mention
[Music]
the lover here get on my back i'm
talking again let's get to the motor
look i'm throwing that [ __ ] in the trash
i man if it's cash you thought i was
wrong
i know you [ __ ] thought
[Music]
all right right now memphis is like the
gold rush for artists
everybody's getting signed and the
reason is memphis has one of the raw's
most authentic cultures but there's a
lot more to it than good music
and good barbecue memphis is the heart
of the bible belt with more churches
than gas stations
on one hand it's that southern
hospitality home of friendly folks who
work hard to get by
but on the other hand it's extreme
violence making memphis the third most
dangerous city in america
it's rural country so practically
everybody's tooled up
and folks have paramilitary weapons in
areas like the south or north memphis
your life expectancy is 20 years shorter
than other parts of the city
right now that's crazy 20 years
shorter my goodness
older than other parts of the city right
now in some neighborhoods
in memphis families are sleeping on the
floor to avoid being hit by gunfire
from outside for some they live in a war
zone
he's from the kane creek apartments in
south memphis just 15 minutes from money
back joe's hood the walker homes
not far from young dolph's neighborhood
and castalia and black youngsters around
the way too
prusheisti growing up was very much on
that killer be killed energy
let his boy big 30 tell you at age 11
shystee thought he was american gangster
getting arrested and expelled from
middle school at the same time
forced to wear an ankle monitor at 11
this little boy is like out here with
bands
like that's so sad eleven-year-old
should not
be in that situation belle from middle
school at the same time
forced to wear an ankle monitor see she
followed in his pops footsteps
pooh's father was a known gangster and
founder of the record label mob ties
in 2006 one of his artists who went by
the name miscellaneous
got into a triple shooting at yogaty's
birthday bash
the club managers knew that yogati and
miscellaneous were beefing
and instead of canceling the event they
hired 35 security guards using four
metal detectors to screen the crowd
it didn't work that same year shaisti's
father was convicted of being an
accessory in the murder of a local
female dj
which put him on supervised parole this
is just like a really
sad story like
why did all why does everyone like kill
each other
that's crazy to me even with the law
breathing down his neck
his pops was still hustling for almost a
year bringing in money under the radar
from a trap house
on a street called porter the house fell
on a dead end and looked like it had
been abandoned but little did pooh's
father know
memphis police have been monitoring the
spot for months one day his father was
in there
they had the measuring cups by the stove
the digital scales on the kitchen
counter one of them had weed the other
had cocaine
suddenly there was a loud boom as the
front door busted open
and cops bursted in rushing apartment 3
that was just up the stairs
as the cops ran up this 75 pound pit
bull came
sprinting around the corner and leaped
at their necks so the officers shot it
three times before the dog retreated to
the kitchen
and later died no
not the dog not the dog
that's just sad and later died in the
chaos you can hear yelling
go go go as people ran from apartment 3
to apartment 4
trying to escape glass shattered as
folks jumped out the window
leaving pooh's father in the kitchen
corner by police
they told him to surrender and he did
leaving the officers with 12.5 grams of
coke
eight pounds of kush and ten thousand
dollars cash that they took
from poo's father's left pocket with his
pops in and out doing fed bids
scheisti was running around a badass
little kid jumping people
finessing people that's how he got the
name shaisti and memphis is a small
world
everybody knows each other shaisty even
went to central high school with some of
the people he's into it with right now
like the main rapper from ebg
e jizzle but pooh's reputation began to
travel in high school he expanded his
circle
clicking up on some plans to get money
by any means together with his childhood
friend big 30
from whitehaven little hank antwop and a
few others
they came up with the name choppagang
and is stuck again
[Music]
within chopper gang there are various
members that come from big
sets that are prominent in the area but
a lot of people don't know
memphis has every single national gang
and more
is extremely active with this new trend
towards hybrid gangs
smaller mobs and clicks within the sets
going renegade
warring with each other seeing where
there was an older person running
everything
but it's been changing a lot a lot of
these young kids with these offsets
okay this is crazy to me
that like
it's so it's just crazy to me that these
kids are in
gangs and like doing stuff like this
like there's other ways to make money
like oh my goodness that's crazy
they're totally different more little uh
cliques or little gangs
that seem to be particularly violent and
need less and less of a reason
to resort to shooting the gun one story
of a guy named white grape or white boy
kenny who went to central high school
with prusheisti in them and was known
for having girls lined up like a buffet
he was a member of chapa gang who got
initiated into the grape street crips
they beat the [ __ ] out of him
took a photo that went viral as he
became an official grape stream member
but one day white grape allegedly got
his gun robbed from him so chopper gang
had to cut ties with him
basically disowning him only for white
grape to catch a murder case
months later after a drug deal went
wrong and clients tried to pay him with
counterfeit money so he
why do you get kicked out of a gang if
you get your gun robbed from you like
wouldn't you
like why that doesn't make sense
like i would think you'd get kicked out
of the gang if like you kill
somebody but well i guess not a gang but
you guys get what i'm saying like he
didn't mean to lose his gun why did he
get kicked out
shot and killed one of them now chop
again continued spreading their
enterprise
planning bigger licks that brought more
danger shiesty himself says before the
age of 15
you're gonna lose a close friend in
memphis guaranteed someone close to you
is going to get killed
around 2016 he lost his best friend trey
day which turned his heart cold
pouches devoured to live with no remorse
from that day forward
and be a menace to society and after he
graduated high school
in 2018 choppaghang had many streams of
income flowing in
and they started using some of this
money they were making to pay for studio
[Music]
time
it was one of those rare cases where the
music blew up out the gate
they dropped their first song breaking
news near the end of 2018
and by 20 oh [ __ ] okay so
it kind of seems like all the [ __ ] they
do is like a marketing
like okay they clearly don't do
all the crazy stuff like just for the
rap music like
that like i'm not dumb clearly like they
have their reasons they want to make
money whatever
but i feel like more people listen to
the music
because it's entertaining because like
they
know these guys are up to like crazy
[ __ ] so they
know that their music is going to talk
about all the crazy [ __ ] they did
and a lot of it's like actually true and
like
so you want to listen to like the
stories of like what happened
2019 they were buzzing shiesty's
childhood friend big 30
got signed the fellow memphis artist
money bag yo meanwhile sheisty was still
a free agent
dropping his singles every other week
racking him views
this caught the attention of guap who
was in the middle of building his 1017
roster
looking for the grimiest artists he
could find of course guap was the
original slime you remember hearing
stories of a young gucci mane
terrorizing the industry famously the
first time he met french montana to do a
song together
french paid him five thousand dollars
and waited in the studio
patiently while gucci took the money and
left out the back door
gucci didn't like french because the
first time he went in the studio
the door saw with him he paid gucci and
five thousand dollars to get on the
feature
and he was just sitting in the studio oh
my god i would be so mad
five grand just to have him leave
that's such a shitty thing to do why
doesn't anyone like
feel guilty i would feel so bad just
taking five grand from somebody
she was going out the back door like he
wasn't doing nothing and i said
you can't do no [ __ ] like that and
that's the same energy gucci saw
in push after hearing one song on
youtube he hit up poo on ig
to get the paperwork ready for a major
label deal with atlantic
chopper gang was laughing to the bank
the industry [ __ ] up and left some
real gangsters in
big scar who's also from south memphis
and just happens to be
poo scheiste's cousin he's a founding
member of a clique called
double r has been in a brutal war at
home in memphis
for quite some time and up until this
point big scar was strictly in the
streets
handling business and never really
considered himself a rapper
until one day he actually blew up off a
reaction video
done by a youtuber named tommycraze who
reacted the big scar's first ever song
when it had only five views
in nine hours how about big scar make a
play
five views nine hours ago man that was
so hard
definitely co-sign this track big scar
make a play
go and check it out that song went on to
do millions of views
and two months later after schaeste
became a major label artist and with
only two songs ever published his cousin
big scar inked a deal with gucci
making chop a gang that's crazy this man
had two songs and got to be that major
that's crazy that's so crazy to me their
affiliates
the single biggest movement coming out
of the mid-south and with all this
attention on memphis
it brought more drama to the city
prusheisti was living up to his name
and began taking shots at another
memphis rapper named big boogie
big boogie the booster where you at
hey boys
me by myself the whole gang right now
right now today in like 30 minutes on
live all this [ __ ]
why you say something back you did that
out of your fans
cause you let your fam boot your head up
boogie's a rising artist out of frasier
which is the north north super country
part of memphis
seems like a good guy according to
boogie they never met a day in their
life
but she claims when he pulled up in the
north to see boogie it was a whole
different story oh you been running for
me bro you've been running you've been
running for me bro
you know what happened in and out bro
when i pulled up came on your side bro
you know what happened and pooh is so
petty he even went as far as naming a
strain of weed
red rum after big boogie's crew red rum
just so he could say
that he's smoking on that red rum pack
and the bigger you get the bigger the
target you become in memphis
just a few days after he went back and
forth with schaeste on social media
big boogies concert in mississippi got
shot up it was the scene of a double
murder
50 shots in total were fired from five
different guns
hitting big boogie's friend jasmine who
was on stage with him and she later died
in boogie's arms
fast forward a few months later to
november 6th
dirk and push isd linked up to drop the
audio for the song back in blood
that's the same day where king von
passed away in atlanta
after an altercation with quando rondo
outside the monaco hookah lounge
chaisti and dirk had already filmed the
music video back in chicago but chose
not to release it yet
this was in many ways the mainstream's
introduction
to pusheisti a few more weeks went by
and the song continued to climb the
charts
then randomly at six in the morning on a
tuesday in december
sheisty posts this cryptic warning to
facebook drop that song and you're not
gonna live to see that baby get here
that's when new years came around
january 1st 2021
a memphis crew called ebg put out a
remix to back in blood
going after sheisty responding to
everything he said on the original track
they got choppagang killer cgk
on their t-shirts pooh responded
immediately saying this had to be the
worst move this gang ever made
and that he did 18 million views off of
them before he even said their name
the very next day sheisty dropped the
music video that he filmed with dirk
back in chicago making back in blood the
trending topic once again
shooting all the way up the billboard
rankings
okay so i don't understand what does it
matter if they said your name or not
like if everyone knows who you're
talking about
like and i don't understand why they're
getting mad about one diss track when
they both made diss tracks
like eg's remix was getting taken down
left and right due to copyrights
so ebg's main rapper e jizzle dropped
another diss track called rumors
which ran up in views quickly hitting a
million views in less than a week
then jizzle was shot three times just
days
after the second diss track went live a
better man can't do this
three bullets hit his arm and after
getting them removed jizzle was back on
the block
wearing a cast just in time to drop his
third diss track
called paralyzed so he got shot and he
was like yeah let me
let me do it again let me just see where
this leads me because
like okay because these people
they have opportunity and they have like
options it seems like like they have
money
can't they like don't they want to stop
so they can like live
a normal night life and not get shot at
or do they
enjoy that
[Music]
to add to the unfortunate timing pouch
isd's brother who have been on life
support
fighting for every breath was pronounced
dead just hours before
ebg released this new diss as it stands
the song has nearly 400 000 views in a
week
ebg jizzle went from a couple thousand
followers
to 50 000 almost overnight and memphis
has pretty much been in a frenzy ever
since
but yeah man let me know if there's a
video you want me to cover in the
comments below
i will see you in the next one that
guy's gonna get killed
um okay
this is an interesting video so my
interpretation of this video
was i mean it's interesting a lot of
things that i didn't understand from
like the previous songs like kind of
made sense like back in blood
i'd reacted to that before and i had no
idea what it was about
i don't understand why people like they
continue to engage with
each other when the outcome is clearly
negative like
do do you enjoy getting shot at do you
enjoy this stuff and especially if
you're rapping and you're making money
that way
it doesn't really make sense to me but
you know i mean obviously i grew up
super different so i'm not going to
pretend to have all the answers
or like i understand at all what they're
going through but
let me know in the comments what you
guys think do you think i'm right do you
think i'm wrong
you guys always let me know what i don't
understand what i got wrong so
feel free to keep that going in the
comments below don't forget and do not
forget to like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe trying to move out of my
parents house
i appreciate every single one of you i'm
gonna talk to you guys next time